Nevada needs more construction workers
the state says there is a labor shortage
and women could help fill the Gap
Candace Charles tells us how women have
started establishing themselves in this
industry
hit that see if there's any
it's another constructive day at the
office for Ashley carrion and then we'll
talk to the subcontractor she is a
project manager for Burke Construction
Group I am very fortunate to have taken
a small part in our ever-growing and
evolving Las Vegas Skyline carry-on has
two decades on her tool belt she's just
one of the women who make up 40 percent
of Bert's Workforce construction is
becoming a more inclusive industry but
that's not the case throughout the state
according to the Nevada state
contractors board only 16 of the
construction Workforce are women it's
kind of an untapped resource Margie
green has been with the contractor's
board for 37 years she tells me there is
money to be made there's only about a
two percent difference for women in
construction versus What men's pay is so
it's a great opportunity in honor of
national women in construction week
which kicks off on Sunday the
contractor's board will hold a Hammers
and hope event for women on Friday it's
a great opportunity for young adults
young women to get out meet people like
myself in the industry and possibly land
a job construction just isn't a an
opportunity for men that the women can
succeed and do just as good or a better
job than a lot of men in the industry
laying the foundation that will change
the landscape of the construction
industry I am here for the Long Haul so
the guys are stuck with me for a while
and that was Candace Charles reporting
Hammers and hope features a panel
discussion workshops and of course job
opportunities it'll be Friday March 10th
at 11 in the morning over at the East
Las Vegas Library